c'est une vie chien d'être en la toute
la journée ben oui d'accord c'est
qu'elle m'a dit un jour une personne il
m'a dit si on vous attachez vous je me
suis pas encore un chien ça viendra
peut-être si je fais réincarner mais
pour l'instant
[Musique]
non les Français auraient-il comme les
Anglais le culte de l'animal domestique
Le chien dit-on est le meilleur ami de
l'homme mais l'homme est-il le meilleur
ami du chien le préfet de Paris vient de
rappeler que les animaux n'ont pas le
droit de dans l'quir ou les jardins de
la capitale sous peine d'amende d'un
minimum de 40 francs pour leur maîre
nous nous sommes promenés dans
quelquesuns de ces jardins ça c anglais
qui a besoin un peu de se dépenser qui
est assez malheureux dans l'appartement
vous l'emmenz par exemple donc ici sur
le jardin de la place ÉtatsUnis est-ce
qu'en principe il a le droit d'être
là je crois pas non c'est au mépris un
peu du règlement que je le fais c'est
qu'il y a beaucoup de gens si vous
voulez qui se plaignent dans Paris des
malpropretés des chiens sur les
trottoirs je sa bien mais moi je moi
j'ai appris mon chien à faire uniquement
dans les canivaux fait t ses besoins
dans les
canivaux ça je je me mets à la place des
visager les trottoirs évidemment c'est
assez désagréable de glisser sur les
besoins des chien mais moi j'ai appris
mon chien à faire dans les canivaux
voyez mal les moindre quand même alors
quand vous trouvez monsieur un
propriétaire de chien qui ne tient pas
son chien en laiss qu'est-ce que vous
faites je l'interpelle je lui fais
attacher son chien ou alors je lui
demand une pié en général ils veulent
pas me la donner parce que
ça ça leur convient pas comprenez alors
déjà leur faire attacher leur chien
c'est déjà tout un problème il pas que
le chien soit
attaché qu'il peuvent pas faire leur
besoins SS
ont moi personnellement je trouve ça
stupide pourquoi écoutez on achète des
chiens c'est pour qu'il sot un peu Liv
déjà dans Paris il y a assez de
difficulté à les promener en la par on
peut pas les promener dans le bois dans
le dans les jardins et dans les bois
c'est pas la peine c'est pas le la faute
du chiens mais la faute des gens quoi
qui mettre le chien dans sur le trottoir
mettre sur partout mais ilut pas le
mettre dans les canivau normalement il
prend l'UD dans son chien il mett dans
son Canau et pass sur les trottoir pass
le parce que les gens il passent le
chaussur il son chauss sale il rent dans
un bureau il estop S avec son al
tap sera partout avec le maire de
chien ok moi je suis absolument d'accord
à T igne que j'ai appris à mon chien de
faire dans un bac comme un chat donc il
a un bac sur le balcon et il fait il
fait la plupart du temps dans son bac ou
alors au bois de Bou il met jamais dans
la
rue c'est vraiment ils sont vraiment pas
très corrects
s était leur fait comprendre que c'est
command même un lieu de promenade alors
ils veulent pas l'admettre c'est une vie
de chien d'être en la toute la journée
bah oui d'accord pe qu'elle m'a dit un
jour une personne il m'a dit si on vous
attachez vous dis je me suis pas encore
un chien ça viendra peut-être si je suis
réincarné mais pour l'instant
non donc vous vous êtes pour la liberté
total des tout à fait même pour la
liberté des chiens non tenus en l'ISE
dans les
[Musique]
ru pas
CER dans certains endroits réservés aux
enfants des mères de famille sont
farouchement opposés à la présence des
chiens oui mais ici je vous dis non il y
a pas de problème on en voit pas
franchement il y a pas d'ailleurs il
aurait pasê toute façon il y a des m ici
avec les enfant s'il y avait un problème
je vous assure que le chien qu' sera
dehors parce
que non ici on en voit pas il y a pas ce
problème là mais dans la contreallé on
en voit de temps en temps dans les
contre all dans les contre allées oui il
y a les les les bonnes femmes qui vient
prener leur chien
[Musique]
mademoiselle vous savez que en principe
vous n'avez pas le droit de laisser
gambader votre chien sur les pelouses
oui je sais mais je préfère qu'il faire
ce besoin sur les pouses que par terre
sur trottoir les gens March toute façon
les pouses sont interdites au
personn moi je ne vois pas de panneaux
sur les pouses interdisant alors je
lâche mon chien il y aura des panneau
interdisant l'c chiens je je
tiend vous avez parfois des ennuis avec
le garde des jardins oui oui plusieurs
fois alors il faut discuter et en
principe ça passe tout seul n'insiste
pas trop surtout avec ce chien sont pas
très rassuré en c'est qui le chien
là c'est à
[Musique]
quien faut le lter de là faut le
descendre
par
interdit les chiens sur les pelouses oui
oui oui depuis quand c'est interdit ah
ben il il y a des panneaux partout et
pourquoi c'est interdit à votre avis ça
ça j'en sais rien mais c'est
interdit les les gens reprochent souvent
aux chiens leur manque de propreté vous
êtes d'accord avec ça oui parce que fa
quand les jardinier ou n'importe qui un
enfant il se met sur la sur les plos il
se sort plein de
destruction mais les enfants sont
interdits sur les plouses aussi non il y
a des plouses qui sont autorisés pour
les enfants ah oui mais alors là les les
chiens n vont pas ah non mais là non
plus ils ont pas le droit non plus moi
je ne vois pas de panneau alors ah ben
il y a des panneaux partout monsieur
mais qu'est-ce que vous faites alors
quand vous trouvez quelqu'un qui qui a
un chien qui se promè normalement le
chien do être tenu en
laiss et il ne doit pas aller sur les
plouses autrement on est obligé
demander l'identité de la personne pour
dresser pr verbal verbal qui coûtera
combien d'argent je peux pas vous
dire nous c'est pas nous qui font ça on
fait les juste les rapports au
[Musique]
brigadiers